real mic [ __ ] wanna listen Mike when I
first did it right I said to myself oh
[ __ ] when I hit it boom oh [ __ ]
because you think you're gonna die yeah
you feel the way you just go to
different chambers you see [ __ ] you know
you think of laughs everything left for
10-15 minutes you still coming out of
[ __ ] Nick we know you love the world you
find pure loving trust becomes your
boundaries to the gases God someone that
you're in right now
incredible [ __ ] having all kind of
issues it's scary sugar you think you're
gonna die you stop can't breathe can't
leave my kids no [ __ ] [ __ ] life
anything to do I can't leave right now
those dying anything that came out yeah
he hasn't been the same since man that's
really been just to see Mike how he was
before that I was a dope fiend thing I
was always doing I can stop cocaine they
go like no Mike Mike our concern oh I
love this money yeah got it Mike Twohey
and and might you would not buy yourself
well let me tell you what's different
this guy it's clear that he is found
acceptance and forgiveness for himself
with the toad and it's beautiful man to
watch this guy